CGI'd eh Michael Douglas is getting CGI
th Jeff Bridges from Tron 2 a run for
his CGI th money if only you'd protected
Janet with such ferocity this sounds
like a terribly mean thing to say to a
guy who lost his wife but realize that
he's only trying to give exposition to
the audience you've already lied to him
now you want to go to war with him yes
wait where the book that your bloody
nose go 26 second Marvel logo can go
consult movie needs to tell you this is
the present-day because honestly Paul
Rudd looks the same now as he did back
in 1989
I'm serious yeah I'm not going back I
got a daughter to take care of do you
not have that same daughter to take care
of before you went to prison because the
only way you didn't is if you only
served like five months or something
which I doubt since that would make you
like a small-time felon who I shouldn't
feel that sorry for welcome to
baskin-robbins
would you like to try our mango fruit
blast baskin-robbins accepted this
product placement slash insult on behalf
of their underpaid employees at first
glance this all looks ordinary and
normal but then you notice the boss
apparently rides a motorcycle the
employee of the month plaque is kept
hanging above the bosses personal sink
the microwave when the Shelf here is not
plugged in there else it would be
displaying the time or flashing 12
o'clock right now and I'm pretty sure
that's a rubber chicken right next to
the microwave then you start to notice
like this near the bottom shelf which
contains a metal bucket a huge
decorative wicker ball and what looks
like a pumpkin shaped candle holder and
starts getting weird now I haven't even
gotten to his bald spot or the two
obvious Fantastic Four Silver Surfer
posters near the doorway
Rudy makes a huge joke out of his
master's in electrical engineering which
buys him a job at King baskin-robbins
which is some total bullsh look mrs.
2015 even with a prison record if you
were some kind of uber genius there is
definitely a job for you out there
better than fast food if you at least
look for it from more than one day I got
fired damn they find who you are why did
you lie to baskin-robbins about your
criminal past
you lied to Merrill Lynch about your
criminal past not King discount Dairy
Queen baskin-robbins always finds a bro
while I'm laughing I'd like to point out
that his buddy Louise knew Scott was
gonna work for baskin-robbins and
somehow didn't tell him this age-old
adage of baskin-robbins always finds out
that's current he was Folsom for five
years he also did a stretch at Arkham
Asylum making him one of the few people
to survive a DC Marvel lockup crossover
nice job yes no no I have heard of this
robbery
I'm not sure you've heard that accent
anywhere though
and what does he do he hacks into the
security system and trances millions
back to the people that they stole it
from and just like that all complexity
and a man's character is erased by some
after the fact noble backstory
reasonable also in an attempt to make
sure we're not rooting for a dirty thief
movie makes Scott out to be a Robin Hood
type where his crime was simply to
punish an even bigger crime little
perfect job no way suppose if friends
try to get just released from prison guy
to do more crime cliche movie tries to
digitize modern-day Stanley onto Michael
Douglas's body holy that's really
Michael Douglas isn't it and ant-man
whoa whoa roll credits but dude you're
gonna have to loop us up before you go
right into a silly name like that at
least describe it as a man the size of
an ant before naming it which should
have been somewhere around the one-hour
mark
and should have at least entertained the
idea of small soldier before discovering
the copyright infringement propaganda
tales to astonish hardy-har capable of
altering the size of the wearer
for the ultimate combat advantage why is
size of an ant the ultimate combat
advantage come to think of it why did
you waste any time on this research
instead of research to make humans ten
times larger an all-purpose peacekeeping
vessel the yellowjacket can manage any
conflict I'm going to guess the guy who
did the voiceover for this Yellow Jacket
video was immediately murdered for
having knowledge about the yellowjacket
efficient in both preventative measures
this is a super huge CGI motion graphics
presentation that had to have been in
production for weeks with a huge team of
people and yet this announcement is
still somehow surprise to everyone here
except the guy making it and the
elimination of obstructions on the road
to peace even industrial videos know
that when it goes down it goes down on
the Golden Gate Bridge I think I found a
guy cue our unlikely hero in some
hilarious situation a kid's birthday
party you might expect me to send Scott
for giving this fucking horrific rabbit
death doll to his daughter but I'm
instead going to send the fact that
anyone would give this fucking thing as
a gift to anyone else what the actual
you can't just show up here movie waste
the awesomeness of Judy Greer in a
thankless role cliche
here Oh Scott yes hasn't he been in
prison for three years isn't she like
five how does she even remember him much
let's make a hero out of him this is how
far the technology is at this point
you're trying to sell this already can't
we have one bad guy who has all the tech
in place before he comes out of the
closet as evil also movie rips off the
crazy science guy kills the military
funding guy before he can shut down the
super soldier experiments thing from
spider-man goodbye Frank Frank flushing
I just shrunk somebody into a tiny pile
of goo face okay I appreciate that the
point of this budget sheet is to show
how committed he is to doing what it
takes to see his daughter again but I
can't let this slide he's making 72
dollars a month but his expenses are
only thirty raise your hand if you can
live on $30 in expenses a month go on oh
wait I said go on also with an income of
72 bucks a month
these rent base numbers over here on the
left are pure fantasy right I don't see
how he hopes to see his daughter in 377
days using these figures more like never
so uh he tells me that she's working as
a housekeeper now right this part is
ridiculously awesome we will remove once
in because this seems like exactly the
type of thing Edgar Wright would have
done how do you stay on the project this
movie just got way more Italian job than
I think it meant to wait you think it
meant to well now that's even worse
isn't it my favorite thing about ant-man
is that the 2-hour movie had time for
the Scott delivers waffles to the hacker
guy scene I can love that scene man
thank God this master thief is also a
master chemist or else this would be a
short-ass movie Ben no alarms you've
been triggered Scott found all the stuff
he needed in Hanks house to make a
fingerprint and get inside the vault in
five minutes okay so far this movie is
MacGyver breaking Ocean's eleven bat
this is the kind of crime where I would
immediately look for the guy who has a
master's in electrical engineering what
has recently released for prison for
theft and stays in an apartment with his
former cellmate now we find out this is
all set up by Hank anyway but even if it
wasn't it's amazing Scott doesn't take
the steps to make this look a little
more amateurs it's a bust
after going through two high-security
vaults Scott's ready to declare this a
bust without checking for secret rooms
or hidden floors or really anything else
in this place sanitize the workstation
bring in subject 35 C why would you
immediately bring in another test
subject after this last one fail don't
you need more research isn't this like a
chemical you're trying to make requiring
lots of lab time or is this guy so evil
he's just killing animals for no good
reason now Hiro looks into a mirror and
wonders what the fuck is up with himself
cliche hey why doesn't he just hit that
button again and grow large any reason
Falls and hits these rusty pipes which
do not break but he does break through
the ceiling of a nightclub no problem he
survives all this crap Garrett Morris
makes a cameo his cab driver in the
scene and he gets to say one line Wow
exactly Garrett Morris exactly you don't
understand
no I don't expect you to because I'm
only going to give you 10% of the
information and the movies barely a
quarter of the way in wait a minute how
does this translate into this chick
telling this guy that Hank has a safe
and someone could break into it did Hank
approach her and tell her one day there
will be some money in your car you know
what to do from there also of course the
idea that this ends up working is absurd
but I'm sending the fact that Hank is
able to mastermind this just before this
asshole Darrin cracks the shrinking code
with the world in the balance you think
he'd need to be more direct than hoping
some mad game of telephone is going to
end up landing the guy he needs to break
into Pym technologies geez why not give
him a little more time to break out than
this you could do this almost any time
right besides getting into the suit in
less than 10 seconds no wait
shut a camera on an ant hey that's my
line his name is 247 is Navin Amy as a
number Scott you have any idea how many
ants there are millions of guessing if
not billions which makes it even more
remarkable that he's somehow riding an
ant with such a low number as 247 to
begin with
definitely no ants in the shot but voila
total ant party when Scott tries to get
out of the bed tiny ants here to serve
as secret service to Scott hey does the
movie ever try to explain how a guy who
invented shrinking technology somehow
managed to bond with literally the
entire global ant population
it doesn't wonderful Scott I've been
watching you for a while ever since you
robbed this to Corp like Gandalf Hank
somehow thought he'd need a burglar for
this job and even though he's got full
access to the building through his
daughter and nearly any trustworthy
person could have put on the ant-man
suit to do what he needed he decided to
have a burglar try out which required a
hundred things to go right before it
could proceed how do you make them do
that I use electromagnetic waves to
stimulate their olfactory nerve center
by over a minute and a half of pure raw
unadulterated exposition so he conspired
against me and you voted me out of my
own
company how can he do that the board's
chairman is my daughter hope hope
doesn't seem to be the I make business
decisions based on my personal feelings
time but then again I guess I'm supposed
to know 43 years of ant-man history
before I watch this movie
silly me Scott I believe that everyone
deserves a shot at redemption that's why
I went looking for my partner in crime
amongst the existing criminals as
opposed to Olympic athletes stuntmen
martial arts experts professional
athletes or even regular people who
haven't committed a crime Darren cross
is a dick to tiny baby sheep that used
to be normal-sized
like honestly can't believe I just wrote
that sentence I think our first move
should be calling The Avengers
yeah but getting all the actors to do an
Avengers movie isn't cost-effective even
though it makes total sense in reality
and oh yeah Scott would be amazing at
cinema since also this is funny but he's
also right which serves to only
exacerbate the movie's weaknesses as
opposed to providing a moment of levity
combined with a decent explanation why
ant-man is on his own and smoothie this
is doesn't shoot technology like the
Iron Man suit whoa whoa whoa besides him
probably too busy dropping cities out of
the sky it's actually Ultron who does
that Hank but nice inside joke I guess
why are you in the suit
you think I don't want to I can't spend
years wearing it it took a toll on me um
that doesn't mean you can't put it on
one last time and save the world right
you're not doing it yourself because of
psychological issues also thanks for
fucking telling me after I've worn the
suit several times ask George big you
dive small then you emerged big why
would you ever need to do that is that
something that he'll specifically have
to do in a short amount of time during
this heist
why can't he simply stay smiling the
whole time and then here's a montage of
him running into a door a bunch isn't
this as simple as pressing a button to
turn small learn about the suit but
you've yet to learn about your greatest
allies he's learned about the suit last
time we checked like a dick this guy
couldn't even charge big dime small and
emerge big invites your greatest allies
the ants but why just because you're
small like them aren't you also small
like fleas flies ticks mites bedbugs and
a host of other insects
the only reason answer involved here is
because some asshole named this soup
thing ant-man and that's looking at
movies definitely turns into Honey I
Shrunk the Kids here there's a security
guard posted
o'clock we'll need you to take them out
to deactivate the security systems or
now stay with me you could just be a
small bastard walk in there and
deactivate the security system without
doing any harm the tube was protected by
a laser grid does it seem like the exact
same blueprint to the death star from
Star Wars read shrinks blue enlarges
want it if you can shrink or enlarge
anything you want why does this movie
have any conflict dude a focus should be
on helping Scott really is that where
focus should be well you keep the
father-daughter conflict big enough I
promise not to care about it deal I
don't know why I came you in the first
place neither do i it seems like you
have more than enough power Pym to
sabotage cross from within think about
Cassie but how badly you want to see her
and use that to focus apparently the
techniques of method acting will make
the mind-control ant thing work I knew I
had to shrink between the molecules to
disarm the missile you mean you didn't
have any technology to shrink and
enlarge a bomb or something that could
destroy the missile before it got to its
target seems like many different ways to
succeed that don't involve shrinking
between molecules also how did you catch
up to this missile as an ant and even if
he could it seems like any fighter jet
could have been called out to
immediately fly out to this location and
blow this thing out of the air also
amazing Hank finally tells hope the
truth after all these years right after
Scott told her that the whole reason her
dad didn't wonder in the suit was
because he didn't want to lose her
furthermore this is some truth that did
not need to remain a secret for any
reason other than a dramatic reveal an
hour into the movie soon I was trying to
protect you good god here's the I was
trying to protect you both in another
movie protect her from what
loving you does he think by telling her
what happened she try to replicate it
ooh my mom went subatomic sounds awesome
when can I try it and considering Hank
locked his suit in a vault somewhere
when was she ever gonna try it anyway
feet go
look I don't doubt that a squad of ants
could jump out of a plane at this
altitude and land anywhere near wait no
I actually totally doubt that problem
you didn't see the Avengers logo until
now dick bat oh yes now we come to the
whole reason why the scene was included
four more Avengers tie-ins everyone's
sitting around thinking you know what we
need to prove that Ant Man is in the
same universe as the Avengers how do we
do that there we can put some cheeky
dialogue in but we really need to see
ant-man interact with I don't know let
me throw this dart Falcon also thank God
Falcon is in this movie to completely
legitimize it with the rest of the
Marvel Universe I mean could you imagine
he can see me Wow Scott does this
without the expectation of immediately
getting his ass kicked and he's right
Falcon is apparently never trying to
kill an ant by stomping on it before
especially in grass this was doomed from
the start it gets to the point that
these suits are so Marvel branded so
much the same neither these characters
look any different from one another
you see that Falcon has the technology
to see small things up close but I don't
know how this dude keeps immediately
finding the exact place where they're
flying in order for it to work it's
really important to me that cap never
finds out about this haha isn't he a
card no seriously watch Captain America
Civil War coming to a theater near you
also where the is everyone else Avengers
related that after beating Falcon
ant-man is able to just do as he pleases
are they like Congress and they all just
go home for several weeks at a time
and why was Falcon here you jeopardized
everything seems like that would have
been the first thing he did once he got
here but now this works better hey how
about the fact that I fought an Avenger
and didn't die well you fought Falcon
who's technically an Avenger yes but
like Lily that Hawkeye is an Avenger
you feel me how did you get in here left
the front door open Hank well sure any
open door means come right in and be a
creepy bastard sure all those years ago
you picked me what did you see
midi-chlorians there's something you
guys need to see something that took 10
seconds while I was in prison will now
take long enough that all of you are in
an entirely different conversation by
the time I get back you know I used to
hate you but now I like you sarcastic
wit mutual admiration confirmed goodbye
how to scare your daughter and possibly
blow your cover in 10 seconds
the Italian impossible 11
skaar wasn't telling the Wiis to shut
the hell up in the scene hey are you
doing do you think I'm not gonna send
the local Nashville actor whom I've met
and joked with and managed to make it
into this big-budget movie playing an
asshole security guard it wasn't very
good at his job
you're dead wrong everyone take that
Jesse James
you've been sinned awesome but how many
ants are dead or dying below the surface
to make this scene possible do we care
of course not this plan presupposes no
one will be in the bathroom will ever
come into the bathroom and not notice
this giant ant infestation
that's prim considering you guys have
been looking for PIM since this morning
and he hasn't exactly been hiding why
didn't you come and knock on his door me
did TI just drive this car around within
running and chasing distance long time
did he basically drive around giving
them hope they could catch it on foot
this guy celebrates too hard and draws
the attention of the very cops he just
tried to distract too many seconds of
this cartoon laser lightshow posing as a
thrilling fight sequence setting the
charges examples of things Hank could
have done to save his wife from
shrinking between the molecules Jesus
how did he get to that space bar
remember when the cops came in well
that's where the computer is and it's
facing the other way yeah this 100-pound
weakling is able to struggle enough with
the cop outside to hit that space bar
just in time
ha you're good delivering lines this way
why did the enlarging blue disks work to
break the glass but he couldn't just
expand his suit to normal size to do it
they use ant machina tank and its
occupants survived this also oh look
they use that enlarging fairy dust magic
to make a tank clearly illustrating my
point about how little conflict there
should be in a movie with this kind of
technology
that means the two guys we saw getting
arrested and are probably responsible
for all this stuff going down at Pym
tech somehow managed to get out of the
handcuffs and back into the getaway van
can a bullet even hit an ant wouldn't
like wind and aerodynamics just slide
the ant out of the way no okay oh and
also
oh no they killed Anthony I almost cared
about him that one time with the things
that happened I guess those bombs were
supposed to make this building implode
like poltergeist and it's the moment
you've been waiting for when two
adversaries fight each other with
basically the same technology it's iron
man an Incredible Hulk all over again
yeaaaah now I have no clue what's going
on but at least there's a cure
soundtrack how is cross suddenly a droid
of fighting in this suit when he only
recently perfected his technology please
hands up yeah they were following the
helicopter a minute ago but it went into
a crazy tailspin an ant-man and
yellowjacket fell while inside a
briefcase which they did not know
contain two tiny Marvel properties so
that they knew where to go is some
bullshit assault no problem can't be
solved with electricity I realize he's
probably mad at Scott to some degree but
he's clearly a wanted fugitive now why
is exacting personal revenge on Scott
more important to him than fleeing and
still selling this one suit to the evil
warlords not just me did these ants come
from the Thomas the Tank Engine sequence
is great but really only serves to tease
what a full Edgar right ant-man would
have been like lots of CGI ants were
harmed in the making of this scene
why is it when someone becomes a
full-blown villain their brain goes into
full top mode
I love how once this ant gets giant he's
like this helping the tiny human bullsh
I'm gonna go find some fruit you might
as well have walked in and said balls
resting on my chin and it would have
made just as much sense does this look
like a guy who's gonna be stomped with
your standard-issue cop gun I'm gonna
have to shrink between the molecules to
get in there my question is is the whole
suit made of titanium I know the back of
it is but surely much of the rest of the
SU is some sort of stretchy material
why doesn't he tear through that and
punch him in the dick several times Oh
what do you mean oh no you knew what you
were getting into before you stupidly
decided to do this
he room gets butterfingers and almost
loses the crucial widget cliche yeah but
if you can't make the regulator work
while it's down here how can you make
the disk work too if the regulator shuts
down because you're tinier than an atom
then doesn't this also malfunction
that's right that's how you could ants
wait look at the girl on wit you'll say
she's pleased to be fine right the
bartender's all like yeah crazy stupid
fine removing Stanley's audio from his
cameo is just half the battle so there
was a secret room in this vault complete
with a keypad but I guess Scott didn't
notice it because there is clearly no
can keypad on this wall and just in case
you weren't excited about the Avengers
three I mean Captain America Civil War
here's a mini teaser that basically says
hey this movie is coming out thanks for
waiting through 7 minutes of credits for
us to tell you that what you already
knew
yeah I always tell myself there's gotta
be something better out there but maybe
maybe I think too much
dude are you gonna hook up with a
Mexican girl trying to hook me up or
don't dude dude it'd be great if you did
forget it man good morning Hank try to
contain your excitement freckles oh by
difficult time he means when my mother
died we lost her in a plane crash well
you want Kern you sold in my file
did you who are you talking about for
Tramel how much did she pay you you've
taken your eye off the ball this is my
own private domicile and I will not be
harassed bitch when you put your hand
into a bunch of goo that a moment before
was your best friend's face know what to
do an analysis of the plans provided by
Princess Lea has demonstrated a weakness
in the battle station